Rudy Guiliani provides a weak defense
for the President of the United States
Asia Argento is implicated in a me-too
mess of her own making and Al Sharpton
makes an astonishingly great TV error
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
oh man I hope you had a great weekend I
cannot wait to play for you al sharpton
'z weekend because it was spectacular
we'll get to that in just a minute first
let's talk about what you are eating for
dinner with your family so you're eating
out a lot I know you are and you're
spending so much money doing it not only
that you're missing out time that you
could be spending with your kids cooking
because it's a lot of fun to cook with
your kids well that is where blue apron
comes in everybody in LA is using blue
apron people all around the office using
a blue apron because they give you quick
and easy recipe options perfectly
portioned ingredients delivered directly
to your door
they make dinner quick easy and insanely
tasty you skip meal planning you get
straight to cooking with blue apron
enjoy the joy of summer with their
favorite grilling recipes they've
seasonally inspired ingredients in
mouth-watering grilling options for the
summer they have chicken with barbecue
sauce juicy cheeseburgers with spicy
slaw which sounds not kosher but
fabulous go check it out right now blue
apron has great recipes and it makes you
basically into a gourmet chef without
you actually having to be good at
cooking so check out this week's menu at
your first three meals for free at blue
aprons comm slash Shapiro Metz blue
apron comm slash compare to get your
first three meals for free blue apron is
indeed a better way to cook them and I'm
looking at some of these meals right now
in front of me they look spectacular I'm
extraordinarily hungry already so this
ad is bad for my health go check it out
right now blue apron calm slash up here
a blue apron calm slash up here and you
get your first three meals for free when
you use that promo code Shapiro okay so
there's a lot going on over the weekend
the big story over the weekend is that
the New York Times supposedly is about
to break open the Muller investigation
everyone very very excited because this
new report from Maggie Haberman and
Michael Schmidt both Pulitzer Prize
winners over at the New York Times
suggest that Don McGann who is president
Trump's attorney in the White House he's
the White House had chief attorney that
this guy spoke to the Muller
investigation and according to the New
York Times this means that Trump is in
for it now
finally Robert Muller is going to seize
president Trump in his clutches
just as the Christine brothers would
want the Christine brothers for folks
who don't know are these people who
basically become famous on Twitter for
tweeting incessantly about President
Trump and then they tweeted over the
weekend a cartoon of a buff shirtless
Chippendale Robert Muller which was real
weird then when people commented on it
they tweeted out buff sure it was
pictures of himself which is even doubly
weird the left is sort of obsessed with
the Muller investigation mega that
impression
New York Times is no exception so here
is what they write president Trump's
lawyers do not know just how much the
White House Counsel Donald F McGann told
the special counsels investigators
during months of interviews a lapse that
is contributed to a growing recognition
that an early strategy of full
cooperation with the inquiry was a
potentially damaging mistake
so at this point in the piece we still
don't know what McGann told the
investigators don't worry we never will
nothing in the piece actually says what
McGann talked to the investigators about
or why it would be so potentially
damaging to the President of the United
States according to the New York Times
however the president's lawyers said on
Sunday that they were confident that mr.
McGann had said nothing injurious to the
president during the 30 hours of
interviews but Mr McGann's lawyer has
offered only a limited accounting of
what mr. McGann told the investigators
according to two people close to the
president that has prompted concern
among mr. Trump's advisors that mr.
McGann statements could help serve as a
key component for a damning report by
the special counsel Robert Muller which
the Justice Department could send to
Congress according to two people
familiar with the discussions what this
suggests is that the Moller
investigation is going to come up with
nothing and then they're going to send a
report to Congress suggesting that the
president acted badly and while he
didn't formally obstruct justice which
is a charge that has a very specific
meaning and involves destruction of
evidence or attempts to intimidate
witnesses or some sort of witness
tampering or perjury the president
hasn't done any of those there's nothing
to actually show the president has done
any of those things
despite that they'll send a damning
report to Congress and then a Democratic
Congress will be forced to try to
impeach mr. Trump's lawyers realized on
Saturday they had not been provided a
full accounting after the New York Times
published an article describing mr.
McGann's extensive cooperation with mr.
Miller's office after mr. McGann was
initially interviewed by the special
counsels office in November mr. Trump's
lawyers never asked for a complete
description of what mr. McGann had said
according to a person close to the
president all of which actually speaks
to the idea that Trump didn't feel like
he had a lot to fear from Mullen right
he let his lawyer over at the White
House go and talk to Muller he didn't
have to do that he could have just
claimed an executive privilege he could
have claimed that there was an
attorney-client privilege he could have
claims a lot of things that would have
prevented McGann from actually having to
go talk with Muller into any of those
things which suggests that Trump doesn't
feel like he really has all that much to
hide and the nerd times continues in
this vein for a very long time means
that pages and pages of writing on this
and there's really nothing
comes out from it basically the only
thing comes out from is that McGann's
people are sort of leaking to the press
it appears that Trump setup McGann for a
possible destruction charge and so
McGann was talking to Muller that's
that's the suggestion in in the actual
article is that the the only thing of
relevance here is that McGann felt
pressured by Trump and therefore he went
and talked to the investigator so here
is here's what the New York Times says
in his article the time said mr. McGann
had shared detailed accounts about the
episodes at the heart of the
investigation into whether mr. Trump
obstructed justice in the Russia inquiry
some of the episodes like mr. Trump's
attempt to fire mr. Muller last summer
would not have been revealed to
investigators without mr. McGann's help
the article set off a scramble on
Saturday among mr. Trump's lawyers and
advisors the president sequestered and
his private golf club in Bedminster New
Jersey solicited opinions from a small
group of advisers and the possible
repercussions from the article the
president ordered mr. Giuliani to tell
reporters the article was wrong but mr.
Giuliani did not go that far in his
television appearances as we'll see
Giuliani went on national TV and said
the president really has nothing to hide
apparently Trump want him to go out and
say that the articles were wrong in all
of their major facts which apparently
was not true in the end is there a lot
here not really not really president
Trump lashed out on Twitter here is what
President Trump had to say about the
article he said the failing New York
Times wrote a fake piece today implying
that because White House Counsel Dan
McGann was giving hours of testimony to
the special counsel he must be a John
Dean type rat but I allowed him and
others to testify I didn't have to I
have nothing to hide okay so people are
picking on the fact that Trump himself
is suggesting that John Dean was a rat
for those who don't know John gene was a
White House attorney under Nixon he went
he talked with Watergate investigators
and it was very damaging to President
Nixon but what Trump is actually saying
here is people are jumping all over him
for this he's not wrong right he allowed
Tom McGann to go and testify now people
are saying at the New Times that Trump
did this basically because he's ignorant
and so he allowed him again to talk to
Muller but again so what does the that's
the opposite of obstruction that's him
actually allowing his own people to go
and talk with them all our investigation
by the way half a dozen people inside
the administration have already talked
to the mother investigation like a lot
of people for hours at a time and you
know what I'm not sure they're gonna
come up with anything but Trump is
frustrated and I think that that's
not completely off the off the rails he
continues along these lines he says
they've demanded transparency said the
rigged and disgusting witch-hunt can
come to a close so many lives have been
ruined over nothing McCarthyism at its
worst yet Miller and his gang of Dems
refused to look at the real crimes on
the other side media is even worse again
I understand why Trump is upset about
this he said my lawyer went and talked
to Muller and you guys are yelling at me
for that and saying that I'm obstructing
even though my guy went and talked yeah
I don't think Trump is wrong I don't
think Trump is wrong again the the the
the sort of implication that Trump is
trying to hide something when he allows
his counsel to go and talk with with the
Muller investigation is a weird one
nonetheless Rudy Giuliani was out there
making the rounds and sort of
demonstrating that Trump was is upset
about the media coverage and Giuliani is
just not a good representative for the
president this is one of the big
problems with representing President
Trump is that every attorney who has
ever represented Trump ends up being
undercut by Trump Trump goes on Twitter
and then blasts out what he thinks
anyway Rudy Giuliani however makes
things worse Ryu Leon E is sort of the
straw that stirs the drink when it comes
to media coverage he was talking about
McGann and he makes a good point about
McGann and then he gets to some much
worse points here's Rudy Giuliani over
the weekend with Chuck Todd of NBC you
don't know how to percent of what he
testified to tomorrow I think that
through through through John dad we have
a pretty good sense of it in John dad
yesterday said I'll use his words rather
than mine that McGann was a strong
witness for the president so I don't
need to know much more about that okay
so if McGann was a strong witness for
the President and McGann went and talked
to the special counsel and in the end
the special counsel has to prove
obstruction the fate not intent not
intent to obstruct actual obstruction
Andrew McCarthy makes this great point
over at National Review today
obstruction is an actual statutory crime
if you're going to prove obstruction you
have to prove that the president
actually took acts designed to stop or
meddle with the investigation there is
nothing to suggest he actually took
these acts he said stuff but saying
stuff does not constitute obstruction
the president has the ability to say as
much stuff as he wants he just can't
commit perjury and he can't actually
engage in witness intimidation that's
not the same thing hey Giuliani then
goes on he
says Robert Muller is panicking and this
time McGann League shows it here's where
Giuliani starts to shade over into a
little bit of dicey territory
it could be McGann and McGann's not
doing it and he would have done it a
long time ago if he was gonna do it
they're down to desperation time they
have to write a report and they don't
have a single bit of evidence okay so it
is very possible the Miller has no
evidence that New York Times report
however looks like a leak from McGann's
team
it looks like McGann is leaking to the
press that the reason that he talked to
Muller is because he was afraid of being
hung out to dry it would be weird if
that leak was coming from team Muller
they're just sentences in the report
that appeared that it makes it look like
it's from them again and then Giuliani
gets himself in the biggest trouble of
all now what Giuliani says in this
particular clip is gonna be wildly
misinterpreted I don't think Giuliani is
completely wrong but expressed in the
worst possible way and in a second I'm
gonna talk about why this sort of stuff
matters
and when you tell me that you know he
should testify because he's gonna tell
the truth he shouldn't worry well that's
so silly because it's somebody's version
of the truth not the truth he didn't
have a a conversation this truth I don't
be to go like I know it isn't truth
truth isn't truth the president United
States says I didn't truth isn't truth
mr. mayor do you realize what no don't
do don't do this to me okay here's the
problem with Rudy Giuliani what he's
saying is not wrong when he says that
there is such a thing as a perjury trap
that if I tell the truth in front of
Robert Muller I still may be brought up
on obstruction charges I still may be
brought up on perjury charges because
it's possible there are two people who
are telling different sides of the same
story and one of them sees it a
different way and therefore a perjury
charge emerges he's not wrong about that
but when he says sentences like truth
isn't truth that is not going to help in
any way Rudy Giuliani is just not a good
representative of the president when it
comes to this sort of stuff what he
should be saying is no lawyer worth his
salt would put his clients in front of a
vey motivated prosecutor determined to
rack that guy up on perjury charges or
obstruction charges no one would do that
particularly not a president who was
fond of speaking off-the-cuff so even if
the president is in general telling the
truth and he makes a slight slip-up
motors gonna grab him and not only that
questions can be asked that are
specifically designed to elicit
a particular response that makes you
subject to perjury a good prosecutor can
do this sort of stuff but saying truth
isn't truth obviously lends itself to
the idea that the Trump administration
is being deeply
dishonest about all the stuff now the
irony is that because the Trump
administration has been dishonest about
so many things regarding the Russia
investigation from the outset it's
obscuring the larger point which is that
Trump I think is probably telling the
truth when he says there was no
collusion but this stuff does have
consequences I'm gonna explain in just a
second first let's talk about whether
you got to go down to the post office
today the answer is you shouldn't have
post office a great place but you don't
actually want to be standing in line at
the post office what you want to do is
save your company time and money by
instead working from your office and
printing out your postage directly onto
envelopes on the stickers directly onto
onto a piece of paper that you can tape
onto your envelope it saves all sorts of
time saves you all sorts of money you
don't have to get in the car and go down
to the post office that's where stamps
calm comes in with stamps calm you can
access all the amazing services of the
post office right from your desk 24/7
when it is convenient for you you buy
and print official US postage for any
letter any package using your own
computer and printer and the mail
carrier picks it up you just click print
mail and you're done it could not be
easier to reuse stamps calm here at the
Daily wire offices I use it at my home
as well it saves me all sorts of time
right now use Shapiro's promo code
Shapiro for this special offer it
includes 55 bucks free of postage a
digital scale and four-week trial go to
stamps calm before you do anything else
click on the radio microphone at the top
of the homepage and you type in promo
code Shapiro that stamps compro Michael
Shapiro when you click on that radio
microphone at the top of page enter
Shapiro and again you get up to 55 bucks
free postage a digital scale and a four
week trial stamps comm all the great
services in the post office directly
from your desk it's fantastic go check
it out
stamps comm use promo code Shapiro okay
so and why does any of this matter in
the end in the end it's all going to be
dependent on what Muller comes down with
so for all the media fomentation for two
years of media elimination all that's
gonna matter is what's in the final
report I have a feeling it's gonna be a
lot weaker than anybody thinks it's
going to be on the left I think that
it's still going to be damning of
President Trump in terms of his own
personal behavior and I don't think much
is gonna come out of it it's just going
to be a rien sort of a restating of
stuff people already knew the big
problem however is that when Rudy
Giuliani goes on TV and says things like
truth isn't truth all it's doing is
underscoring the dishonesty of the Trump
administration time and time again
during the Russia collusion
investigation the broader point that
Trump is making I did not
with the Russians to change the effects
of the election I think is probably true
because there has not been evidence
presented yet to show that the Trump
campaign actively colluded with the
Russians in shifting the election there
is attempt there is intent that's not
the same thing as active collusion and
coordination to violate the law in
pursuit of changing the electoral result
but because the Trump administration
because the Trump campaign was so
dishonest about the Trump Tower meeting
for example because Rudy Giuliani has
shifted his story multiple times
it makes Trump look dishonest and it
occurs to me what a problem that says
yesterday I took my wife for her
birthday glass blowing so we've never
done this before and and my sister
actually suggested this we'd like to do
sort of arts and crafts sorts of things
visit is a new thing we like to do kind
of experiences for birthdays and
anniversaries instead of me just getting
her a nice piece of jewelry
or in addition to me getting her a nice
piece of jewelry but in any case we
decided to go glassblowing and the woman
who's teaching the class is of course as
you imagine in Los Angeles somebody
who's very much on the left and we start
talking about politics because she
brings it up I was not all that
interested but she wanted to and so he
started talking about politics and she
started talking about what a bad guy
Trump was and I said but his policies
really haven't hurt you in any way in
fact the economy's been pretty good yeah
his policies are stuff that you kind of
like and she's you know who else I
dislike that Mike Pence that Mike Pence
is just terrible I said well you know I
know the vice president pens he's
actually kind of a nice guy and the idea
that he has some sort of grave granthia
crap attempting to govern you from above
I just don't think that's true and then
she starts launching into Mitch
McConnell and after a little while of
this it occurred to me the policy just
doesn't matter when it comes to people
voting the vast majority of people vote
and think based on their personal like
or dislike of particular people and
candidates people don't think in terms
of policy people don't think in terms of
truth or falsehood in the Russian
collusion investigation all they think
is is Trump dishonest or is Trump not
dishonest and so even if Rudy Giuliani
is not wrong about perjury traps and
Robert Muller when you represent the
worst face to the public that has
serious electoral consequences that
stuff that doesn't get brushed under the
rug when it comes time for people to
vote the grand perception of President
Trump is a dishonest guy is not going to
be dissipated by the constant
reiteration by his counsel Rudy Giuliani
of that sort of diss
honesty and that feeling of dishonesty
it's this miasma of bad stuff
surrounding the Trump administration
that does more harm than the actual
criminality cuz I don't think there's
actual ending criminality when it comes
right down to it okay meanwhile the
media I of course have every interest in
blowing up everything bad about
President Trump to inordinate heights of
outrage and that's not helping either so
the media continue to take very
seriously
Omarosa Manigault even though she has
had nothing that's what's really
astonishing about the Omarosa Manigault
story so Omarosa is going around talking
incessantly about all of the tapes she
has she has not released one seriously
damning thing about the Trump
administration she really hasn't now all
she said is that she didn't get along
with Trump she can get along with John
Kelly and now she says Trump was a
racist after spending years talking
about a wonderful president Trump was
and had literally bow before him now
she's going around and she has her in
strange new respect from the media so
she's gotten most of that strange new
respect courtesy of the folks over at
places like MSNBC in a grand meeting of
the minds
al Sharpton had on Omarosa on MSNBC over
the weekend and they were talking about
race from Al Sharpton a man who is
legitimately participated in the
inception of race riots in places like
New York morosa talking with Al Sharpton
race baiter par excellence about why
Donald Trump is gonna start a race war
we have a lot to lose and in fact we're
losing right now because Donald Trump is
disingenuous about his engagement in his
outreach and in fact I believe he wants
to start a race war in this country no
for a lady who was fired from the
administration did not quit it's pretty
wild for her to suggest that Trump wants
to start a race war in the country it's
particularly rich for her to be saying
this to a guy who legitimately has
started race riots in the United States
or at least allegedly been involved with
the inception of those race riots
particularly the 1991 race right and
Crown Heights that claimed the life of
North that ox Jew but I guess that the
media have to be treated with respect
her al Sharpton certainly has to be
treated with respect the worst battery
of Al Sharpton's weekend was not
actually his interview with Omarosa it
was the lead-up to his interview with
Omarosa
this is real I'm not making this up this
is a thing that actually happened on
national television is it fair to say al
Sharpton is a dummy I think that based
on Clips like this the the ongoing
battle between Al Sharpton and his
teleprompter is one of the great battles
in human history I mean it really is
like the it's like the
Battle of Stalingrad really gal sharpton
versus his teleprompter so here is the
best clip of the weekend bar none it's
just fantastic you know what they say
about payback it's a real well you I'm
sure you know the word I'm thinking of
so in the words of my late friend Aretha
Franklin and show some RESP ICT oh my
goodness
well you just hope that out Al Sharpton
is never in a position where he's on
wheel of fortune and you have the art of
the s the P to C on the T and then you
have to buy a vowel because my goodness
r it's literally almost payments so on
RESP i CT tell us what it means to Al
Sharpton ah just fantastic stuff I can't
imagine why folks don't take the media
seriously but again the media continue
to to portray the Trump administration
as a place in flux and chaos they
continue to give lots of respect to
people like John Brennan a guy who lied
to Congress a guy who was involved in
basically smuggling classified
information over to John over to Harry
Reid in the Senate so he could make
trouble for during the last campaign
here was John Brennan on national TV
talking about Trump is treasonous and
media are all in on the idea that Trump
is is a treason a treasonous fellow the
reason again this is relevant is because
the Trump team has to fight back on that
perception and making batteries with
Rudy Giuliani is not the way to do this
I called his behavior treasonous which
is to betray one's trust and to aid and
abet the enemy and I stand very much by
that claim you are the former CIA
director accusing the sitting president
United State that's that's monumental
accusation well I think these are
abnormal times and I think a lot of
people have spoken out against what mr.
Trump has done and maybe it's my my
warning training as an intelligent
professional I have seen the lights
blinking red in terms of what mr. Trump
has done and is doing now as possible
but let's can go too far even for the
left so James clapper
who was a former head of the CIA I
believe under under Barack Obama the
clapper actually started talking he's
former Director of National Intelligence
under President Obama even he says that
Brennan has gone too far here so even as
the Trump campaign the Trump
team Rudy Guiliani fail on their lines
folks on the left are failing on theirs
right so so John Brennan starts ripping
into James clapper and he's exactly
correct heard of the opposite clapper
starts ripping on Brennan he's exactly
right here you know John is sort of like
a freight train and he's gonna say
what's on his mind but John and his
rhetoric had become I think an issue in
and of itself so just great stuff there
the fact is that the left are attacking
themselves over how far they can go over
president Trump again the focal point of
politics has become the presidents of
the United States it's the job of the
presidents of the United States to make
himself more popular it's the job of the
left to make him more unpopular every
time the left goes too far it makes
Trump more popular every thought every
time president Trump sends out Rudy
Giuliani to botch the message on
national television
it makes Trump less popular that is the
battle that's going on it's a battle of
incompetence people beating each other
with sticks it's it's it's really a
clown show out there and on the highest
possible level the only way this is ever
gonna get sorted out is the next ballot
box and that is a problem for
Republicans because again the
president's popularity rating is not as
high as it should be right now given the
geopolitical situation okay in just a
second
I want to talk about the me2 movement
and whether it is foundering on the
rocks of its own radicalism first let's
talk about your safety and your security
so ring Tom's mission is to make
neighborhoods safer today over a million
people use the amazing ring video
doorbell to help protect their homes
ring nose home security begins at the
front door it does not end there so now
they've extended that same level of
security to the rest of your home with
the ring floodlight cam just like that
amazing doorbell floodlight cam is a
motion-activated camera and floodlight
it connects right to your phone with HD
video and two-way audio that lets you
know the moment anyone steps on your
property I love my ring doorbell I mean
it's just it's fantastic the video
doorbell it means that when I'm out of
town somebody can ring the doorbell it
pops up on my phone I know who's outside
my house which is a big thing for me I'm
very safety oriented ring calm can do
that for you except extended all the way
across your property with the floodlight
cam as well with the floodlight cam when
things go bump in the night you will
immediately know what what it is whether
you're home or away the ring floodlight
cam lets you keep an eye on your home
from anywhere ring floodlight offers the
ultimate in home security high
visibility flood lights a powerful HD
camera that puts security in your hands
with ring you are indeed always at home
save up to one hundred and fifty bucks
off a ring of security kit when you go
to ring.com slash
that's ring.com / Bennigan's ring.com /
been use that / been so we know we sent
you and so you get that special deal 150
bucks off a ring of security kit love my
ring comm products and you will to go
check it out ring comm / been for that
special deal okay so the other big story
of the weekend is that Asia Argento who
is one of the lead figures in the me2
movement it turns out that she was
actually involved in paying off a 17
year old for sexually assaulting him in
a California hotel room here is the
story from the New York Times the
Italian actress and director Asia
Argento was among the first women in the
movie business to publicly accuse the
producer Harvey Weinstein of sexual
assault she became a leading figure in
the hashtag me - movement her boyfriend
the culinary television star Anthony
Bourdain eagerly joined the fight but in
the months that followed her revelations
about mr. Weinstein last October miss
Argento quietly arranged to pay three
hundred and eighty thousand dollars to
her own accuser Jimmy Bennett a young
actor and rock musician who said she had
sexually assaulted him in a California
hotel room years earlier when he was
only two months past his seventeenth
birthday which would be statutory rape
she was 37 the age of consent in
California is 18 that claim and the
subsequent arrangement for payments are
laid out in documents between lawyers
for Miss Argento and mr. Bennett a
former child actor who once played her
son in a movie the documents which were
sent to the New York Times through
encrypted email by an unidentified party
include a selfie dated May 9th 2013 of
the two lying in bed as part of the
agreement mr. Bennett who is now 22 gave
the photograph and its copyright to Miss
Argento now 42 three people familiar
with the case said the documents were
authentic miss Argento's and her
representatives have not responded to
any of this mr. Bennett who lives in Los
Angeles would not agree to be
interviewed as he said his lawyer Gordon
SOT Roe in the coming days satra wrote
in an email Jimmy will continue doing
what he has been doing over the past
months and years focusing on his music
mr. Bennett is a child actor who charmed
Harrison Ford Bruce Willis earned the
nickname Jimmy two takes because he
rarely flubbed his lines the 2013 hotel
room encounter was a betrayal that
precipitated a spiral of emotional
problems according to documents the
fallout from a sexual battery was so
traumatic and hindered mr. Bennett's
work and income threatened his mental
health
mr. Argento subsequently turned to miss
Goldberg who's a lawyer to handle the
case mr. Bennett's Notice of Intent
asked for 3.5 million dollars in damages
for the intentional infliction of
emotional distress lost
wages assault and battery mr. Bennet
made more than 2.7 million in the five
years before the 2013 meeting with Miss
Argento his income has since dropped to
an average of 60 grand a year and he
attributes that to the trauma with
regard to to this particular incident so
that's really really ugly stuff now a
lot of people are using this to try and
discredit the broader me to movement
suggesting that if Asia Argento has been
responsible for the sort of sexual
battery herself and covered it up that
the credibility of some of the leaders
of the Miche movement is compromised
there's no question that her credibility
is compromised but the idea of the meets
you movement which is that sexual
assault is bad is obviously true but
again radicalism tends to discredit the
main ideas underlying some good
movements and this is what we're seeing
in politics is what we're also seeing
with cases like the me2 movement
speaking of radicalism there's an
article in The New York Times again it's
amazing the most motivated people the
most motivated people in life tend to be
the people who are radical those also
tends to be the people who are most
likely to undermine the mainstream
credibility of their own message most
people if they move on issues want to be
moved incrementally they don't want to
have things shoved in their face they
don't want radical shifts in the way
they think about things but radicals by
nature want to shift things radically
the way people think about things the
problem is those radicals very often end
up alienating the very people that they
seek to draw in the latest example from
the New York Times there's a full
article in The New York Times I'm not
kidding it it's by a woman a person
named sana are not sure if this is a man
or woman the article is titled
witchcraft in the me2 era if you want to
make the case for me too if you want to
make the case against sexual assault you
probably don't want to start with
witchcraft
mmm witchcraft in the me to ear is
actually basically the plot of the
crucible by Arthur Miller but the New
York Times reports Vesely in a secluded
nook of Central Park thirteen witches
student his circle on a cloudless
Saturday eyes close chanting a makeshift
altar on the forest floor bro Lantern a
silver chalice a bowl of water a jar of
salt a sunflower and a wand Denice kruky
High Priestess of the north will would
coven and her coven mate Joanne Ferrer
guided the group through midsummer an
annual ritual celebrating the summer
solstice in a billowy white skirt and
flip-flops ms crew she resembled a
free-spirited flower child I do love the
romance
that the New York Times gives witchcraft
and people who are crazy because they're
part of a coven I do love that they
don't talk this way about Jewish ritual
they don't talk this way about Catholic
ritual they don't talk this way about
Protestant ritual but a bunch of nuts
gathering the middle of Central Park get
this sort of treatment from the New York
Times and then they wonder why maybe the
me2 movement is stalling out a little
bit here when you undermine your own
credibility by embracing radical
silliness this is sort of what happens
the Temple of the spiral path which
includes the North willed wood and
stranger gates covent has performed
rituals in this clearing known among the
witches as the green cathedral for 20
years the worshippers sat cross-legged
around a circle of flowers dried kulinda
chamomile lavender and rose petals
carefully arranged in a spiral ms cruci
led them through a meditation then they
slowly joined hands began singing and
one by one they entered the spiral their
dancing crew increasingly raucous as
they in tone we are a circle moving one
with another we are moving together we
are one in such a large and diverse City
says the New York Times it is no
surprise that the craft is fairly
accessible if you know where to look
nearly 880 covens and Pagan
organizations operate in the New York
metropolitan area according to the pagan
networking site The Witches voice which
sounds quite awesome nationally about
seven hundred and thirty four thousand
Americans identify as pagan or Wiccan
according to a 2014 Pew Research survey
which is fewer than the number of people
who listen to this show daily so it's
not exactly like a burgeoning mass
movement all across the country
apparently ten thousand witches live in
practice in New York I don't know what
it means to practice witchcraft I guess
that you like to ride a broom in any
case this sort this sort of thing is not
I think good for association with the
media movement but radicalism always
tends to draw a bunch of people who are
the most enthusiastic and we're seeing
it in our politics as well so we're
seeing with the me2 movement as some of
its leaders are some of the most morally
questionable and radical people even
though the Miche movement has some
underlying good points to make we're
seeing it also with regard to our
politics where the most radical people
from both sides are tending to hijack
movements that actually have some
credibility to them so on the right you
have people like Kelly Ward Kelly Ward
is running in a primary in Arizona right
now against martha mcsalley martha
mcsalley
is a MA
federer candidate she's a representative
from Arizona former Air Force colonel I
believe who is a the first woman to fly
in combat if I'm not mistaken her record
is pretty sterling Martha Maxim mix
Alice she's run against Kelly Ward who
is Penniman nutcase and Kelly Ward is
running around to him with Mike Serna
Mitch a guy whose most famous for
promoting pizza gate she was on MSNBC
and she's promoting her candidacy by
saying that she doesn't know who Mike
Serna audiences but she wants to
appeal to them also it's very easy for
radicals to get a lot of attention and
Kelly Ward is getting a lot of attention
specifically because folks on the Left
have an interest in elevating her and
also because radicals again are some of
the most outspoken and loud and
entertaining people in America I mean
Mike Serna vich has an audience that we
want to reach and that includes
Republicans conservatives liberals
Democrats people of all ilk sand so if
he's coming on the bus tour I think that
he'll have a voice and he'll have
something that he wants to say meanwhile
on the Left what you're seeing is the
complete seduction of the Democratic
Party into hardcore actual socialism
even though they won't actually define
their terms there's an interesting
column by Elizabeth brew dick who is the
the in house socialists over at the
Washington Post the irony of course is
that I couldn't access this column
without actually paying for the pay wall
even though it's about the glories of
socialism so that's too bad but we'll
get to that in just one second first
you're gonna have to go for daily wire
comm and subscribe for $9.99 a month you
get a subscription to daily wire when
you do you get the rest of this show
live you get the rest of the Android
clava and show live you get the rest of
the Michael Noel's show live if that's
something you're interested in or into
also you for $99 a year you get this the
very greatest and beverage vessels
leftist tears hot or cold tumblr go
check it out right now
you will live it you will love it and it
replenishes daily so go check that out
right now when you subscribe at YouTube
or iTunes you also get access to our
Sundays special last week we had on Greg
Gutfeld this week we're having on
someone similarly interesting I don't
know who it is yet but it will be
someone great I promise so go check that
out right now we're the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
so as I say every major movement in the
United States right now is in danger of
being taken over by radicals because
radicals are the most motivated part of
any base I've talked about the process
of renormalization before on the show is
a term that that was used by the the guy
who wrote skin in the game
Nassim Nicholas Taleb the basic idea is
this big groups tend to surrender to
small groups of very motivated people
that's just the way life works if you
are a family and one daughter is vegan
very soon you will all be eating vegan
because mom or dad does not want to
bother with actually making two separate
dinners for everybody one meat and one
vegan instead everybody will just eat
vegan and suddenly the whole family is
vegan and then when that family goes to
a party and the whole family is vegan
the entire party becomes vegan because
it's a lot easier and cheaper the
transaction cost of having to cook two
meals is higher than the transaction
cost of just going along with the most
radical people in any part of the base
you want to satisfy the base because the
base is the loudest and the most
polarized so you see this with regard to
the me2 movement where every accusation
has to be taken with equal seriousness
no matter how stupid no matter how
unjust which is bad for the me2 movement
because it undermines the credibility of
the me2 movement you've seen it with
regard to the right where a lot of folks
who should not be given credibility have
been given credibility because they are
the most motivated and you're now seeing
it on the part of the left where
democratic socialists are taking over
the mainstream Democratic Party because
the Democratic Party wants to cater to
its most motivated base the people who
go out and knock on doors
so Elizabeth brooding who is the
in-house socialist over at the
Washington Post her husband Matt
burnings they're both nice people I've
talked to at least Matt and he seems
like a nice guy
both of them are socialists NAT runs
something called the Public Policy
Institute which is it which is a 501c3
pushing socialism but not really
socialism kind of pushing Nordic
socialism which is not quite the same
thing well Elizabeth brooding has a
column today about why it's time to
reclaim socialism from the dirty word
category the problem for her is that she
actually doesn't want to define what
socialism is because socialism is
inherently radical you can find
socialism however you want some people
define socialism as stuff I like from
the Nordic countries and some people
define it as getting rid of the profit
motive which is how the democratic
socialists of America do the goal of
socialists is to pretend they are not
what they are which is radical so here's
elizabeth burnings column
you'll see how she's sort of obfuscating
the terminology she's using in order to
cover for her own radical agenda so
here's what she says a Gallup poll this
month found the Democrats are warming up
to the idea of socialism or at least to
the word well 57% of Democrats polled
said they view socialism positively only
47% said the same of capitalism down
from 56% in 2016 Republicans meanwhile
remain pretty enthusiastic about
capitalism with 71% rating it positively
still 16% of GOP voters said they even
view socialism through a friendly lens
which raises the question when Americans
say they've used socialism one way or
the other what exactly do they have in
mind the United States doesn't have a
familiar established socialist history
to look to for guidance on what
socialism might mean in this country
that's not actually true there was a
Socialist Workers movement led by Eugene
Debs in the early 20th century that
actually became relatively popular and
that's because it was full scale
nationalization of industry socialism
generally means that the government runs
the economy it is centralized planning
at a central planning from the top of
the economy including up to and
including full-scale nationalization of
resources without regard to profit
motive that would be sort of the usual
mechanism by which socialism runs what
the left has tended to do is redefine
socialism as capitalism with some
socialist redistribution as policies on
top so what's weird about that is John
take for example John rockefeller so the
Rockefeller family earned an enormous
enormous amounts of money in capitalism
then they gave an enormous amounts of
money to charity where they capitalists
or socialists I would say they were
capitalists who gave to charity perhaps
if you're going to say that charitable
giving forced by the government and
socialism what you would say is that the
Rockefellers were actually socialists
because they used capitalism in order to
create this enormous amounts of wealth
and they redistributed the wealth what
that really is is the growth on genna's
capitalism and the redistribute of
mechanism is socialism and this is why
breaking down each particular policy is
sort of important so we can determine
whether a policy is good but calling the
entire country socialist or capitalist
unless you're talking about Cuba which
is entirely socialist makes very little
sense but that's not where Bruton goes
what she does instead is she refuses to
define the term she says the United
States doesn't have a familiar
established socialist history to look to
for guidance on what socialism might
mean in this country but that doesn't
mean socialism is hopelessly nebulous or
that Americans who are interested in the
idea are wandering dabblers it just
means that socialism like any
sophisticated term warrants thoughtful
consideration socialism has meant
different things to different
people in different times and places
while maintaining a stable core of
themes and objectives social as opposed
to private control of the means of
production okay now she's talking about
nationalization you would think and of
all the societal humanitarian and
political economic changes that entails
especially our freedom and autonomy of
working people are concerned again this
is extraordinarily vague because if you
say does that mean nationalization
she'll say what maybe and then if you
said what does that mean that workers
are supposed to take over the factories
you'd say well maybe but it's not
specific enough for us to actually dig
down so what she's doing is smart
because she's attempting to guys her
radicalism in this sort of vague
incrementalism she is the term itself
socialism came into being in the early
decades of the 19th century and like any
good word inspired a great deal of
imagination for the non Marxian English
socialists of the 1840s socialism mainly
meant to opposition to the competitive
dehumanizing effect of liberal economies
local experiments with communitarianism
and cooperatives and demands for the
privileges of freedom autonomy and
participation in government to extend to
the lower classes none of which would
actually define as socialism per se
because if you and your family decides
to get together and do a co-op that's
not quite socialism if it's private if
you just meanwhile Marxian socialism
folks focused on the conditions of
production who owns what the
relationships between wage earners and
owners and how stuff gets made in a
society and the kind of politics these
conditions produce even when socialism
was a relatively new term in other words
its exact meaning was disputed and what
burning is basically going to do here is
obscure that there is such a thing as
socialism instead what she's going to do
is just claim that all the stuff she
likes - socialism and all the stuff she
doesn't like is not socialism which is a
smart way of sort of ushering socialism
into the mainstream but it's also a
dishonest way and I'll explain more in
just one second
so brunnen continues she talks about now
as in the 19th century confusion about
what socialism means is stoked by
political interest in clouding the issue
as Eric Levitz notes in New York
Magazine conservatives tend to oscillate
between arguing that successful
countries such as Finland Norway and
Denmark generally regarded as socialist
are actually as capitalist as the United
States and claiming as fox business
networks trish regan recently did that
socialism has made these countries
stagnant and stultifying well no both
are actually true both all of those
Scandinavian countries are based on a
foundation of capitalism there is no
question than what earns the profits in
Finland Norway and Denmark is not their
socialist means of production
it is profit-seeking incentives that is
what it's created all growth curve in
Scandinavian countries for as long as
human history because socialism has
never created serious growth in any
country state-sponsored capitalism is
merely the state using capitalistic
profit seeking methods in order to
subsidize particular industries which
creates growth in those industries but
sucks growth out of other industries but
socialism is the idea that the profit
motive doesn't matter and we ought to
redistribute all resources again
obscuring the terminology is an easy way
of preventing people from understanding
what socialism means I like that
Elizabeth running concludes this way
clarifying exactly what socialism means
once and for all likely won't happen
anytime soon but that doesn't mean
voters who are attracted to democratic
socialist politicians such as senator
Bernie Sanders and House candidate
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez don't know what
they're getting into
proposals to wipe out the so-called
right to work laws to make college
tuition free or to provide universal
health care are resonating with those
supporters at the heart of the
democratic socialist vision finally
should gets to her definition after all
of that here is her definition of
socialism at the heart of the democratic
socialist vision flowering on the
American left is the recognition that
more than policy tweaks will be needed
to empower everyday people to
participate meaningfully in society and
democracy
this is where she strips finally away
and what we are left with is radicalism
the radicalism at the heart of this
program taking over the Democratic Party
now you have to hide it but this is
really what's going on
she's working Americans deserve a say in
how the country's vast wealth will be
used it's not the country's vast wealth
it is wealth earned by individuals who
are working hard and playing by the
rules and employing other individuals
like treating all wealth as a collective
is the way that you actually get to
gulags the direct line between the
country owns all the wealth and the
gulags is actually relatively short this
is working Americans deserve a say and
how the country's vast wealth will be
used and that will be possible only when
inequality is reduced corporate and
big-money donors are banished from
politics and lawmakers are truly
accountable to the people it's not so
much to ask but democratic socialists
are the only one asking which of course
is not true when you talk about
corporate and big-money donors being
banished from politics I assume she's
not talking about the Washington Post
which is a giant corporation involved in
politics all the time I assume she's not
talking about her husband's public
policy institute which is deeply
involved in taking large donations I
assume from donors who then wish to
promulgate a political agenda and
she says lawmakers being fully
accountable to the people it seems to me
that the Tea Party was acting for
exactly the same thing so the Socialists
played this double game just like
radicals often do of pretending that
they are not radical but then at the end
stripping away all of this in favor of
their radicalism this is why it's
important to identify I think that there
is a common sensor to the country still
there's still a group of people in the
country
who wish to have intelligent
conversation about actual terminology
but that can only happen when we get
down to the actual root of the issues so
if we want to have a discussion about me
too then it can't all be about Harvey
Weinstein and Asia Argento instead it's
got to be about what social standards we
wish to purvey when it comes to sex and
sexuality we can have an honest
conversation about what conservatives
and looks like but that cannot be a
conversation about whether Mike Serna
vich and his crowd are worth catering to
hey we can have an honest conversation
even about the the lengths to which we
should redistribute resources in the
United States I think very little
there's a lot of people think a lot more
but we can't do that so long as people
are skating and hiding all this under
the rubric of democratic socialism
because what they mean is being
deliberately obscured the radicals are
taking over a lot of areas of American
life because they are the loudest and
because they shout the loudest and
because they get the most media
attention and because both sides have an
interest in highlighting the most
radical people on the other side in
order to clarify the distinctions
between the sides but the only way we're
gonna have a common conversation as we
get down to the roots of actual
terminology and explain what we mean
because then we can actually discuss
what works and what doesn't but people
have a real interest in being as radical
as they want to be while guising it in
the language of broader movements Asia
Argento and company have an interest in
taking a radical agenda and guising it
as me too broadly
witchcraft and me too it's all the same
thing that's foolish take inflation of
good ideas with bad ideas or conflating
ideas we can all agree about with
radical ideas is the way that politics
ends up becoming polarized and
radicalized and then we have no common
sense or for us to have a conversation
anymore okay time for some things I like
and then we'll get to some things that I
hate so things I like I'm recommending
this book a little bit early to book by
Oren cast nothing come out I believe
till November but you can pre-order it
right now it's called the once in future
worker now Oren cast and I disagree on
elements regarding free trade for
example he's a lot more trade
restriction astern
certain ways he's still in favor of
trade but he's more trade restriction
ascend I am in certain ways although I
think he might argue he's more free
trade than I think he is he is a a
really good thinker over at the
Manhattan Institute who talks about why
it is that certain jobs in the United
States and the manufacturing base
particularly have been hollowed out his
suggestion is that it has something to
do with technology but it has more to do
with the fact that we have made our
business environment uncompetitive
through environmental regulation in
certain areas and through union
contracts as governed by the National
Labor Relations Act he makes a case for
actual adoption of certain European
styles with regard to for example unions
and education and this is the part
that's really fascinating there are good
conversations to be had about why there
is less income inequality in certain
areas of Europe or why education is
better in Sweden than it is in the
United States no one wants to have those
actual conversations instead we all want
to do bumper-sticker stuff about why
Sweden is spending so much of its GDP on
government redistribution ISM why not
instead look at what they're actually
doing with regard to education so in
Sweden everybody is tracked so for
example in the United States there are
no tracks right we all go to the same
classes and then we get to decide
whether to go to college and everybody
has the opportunity to go to college in
Sweden in Israel in a lot of other
countries what they do is by the time
you are in eighth grade
you're basically deciding is this a
person who's ready for college or is a
person not ready to go to college if
they're not ready for college we get
them an apprenticeship program or they
actually are learning practical skills
for a job they're going to do now you
can move between tracks you're not stuck
there forever it's not like we just trap
you in there but you actually have to
achieve to move from one track to
another and you also have to seriously
think about whether everybody is fit for
college in the United States the model
seems to be if you don't go to NYU for
any reason then you are going to be poor
and that's foolish that's foolish you'd
be better off if a lot of the folks who
are not going to college the college
attendance rates by the way have been
pretty stable in the United States for a
fair bit of time and that's because
there are a lot of people who just
aren't ready for college and instead it
ought to be prepped for a job Orin Cass
talks about a lot of these sort of
policy solutions that nobody wants to
talk about the book is well worth
reading it's the one set in future
worker go check it out right now it's a
sophisticated take on a lot of deep
policy issues and and worth checking out
ok time for a couple of things that I
hate
as I mentioned earlier ELISA on the left
who are deep believers that character is
that a finding issue in politics except
when it comes to people on their own
side and this means that they're going
to be as radical as they want to be so
Alyssa Milano tweeted this out over the
weekend she tweeted out a picture of
herself in what looks like a Little Red
Riding Hood costume it's like she didn't
even she could even afford to go get the
full Handmaid's Tale costume so she went
out and she got like a Little Red Riding
Hood costume and she put it on and then
she tweeted out holding a sign that says
never Cavanaugh never gilead because
justice Cavanaugh had justice Cavanaugh
on the Supreme Court would apparently
usher in the era in which women were
just essentially birth mothers who were
raped at will
because that's what justice Cavanaugh is
all about I mean if you hadn't noticed
that's clearly is his deal and she
tweeted out hashtag rise up--for ro
hashtag we are not property hashtag stop
Cavanaugh the the character
assassination is is pretty astonishing
and somewhat hilarious but demonstrative
of how people on the Left really want to
see their political opponents people on
the right do the same thing with regards
to their political opponents who
everybody is a demon everybody's a devil
but I think right now the level of
demonization on the left of the right is
a lot higher than the demonization of
the right by the of the right to the
left so anyway she's not the only one
Bill Maher over the weekend he says that
President trumpets he's obviously a
Russian asset it's not the president
Trump is a doofus it's not the President
Trump yeah I mean I asked Bill Maher
this on his program is Trump a doofus or
is he an evil genius and Mars answer was
he's Hitler which was a weird answer but
Bill Maher is now saying it is obvious
that President Trump is a Russian asset
this sort of character assassination is
dishonest it's somewhat effective in in
making the radical base more pumped up
if they're radical if pumping up the
radical basis all politics is gonna
become all common conversation goes away
here's Mar pumping up the radical base
I'm sorry but it's super obvious already
he is a Russian asset this has been
going on since the 80s they were
targeting for this and Bob Miller's
report is just gonna be what this movie
and this book is yes will you hope so
with even more is it's going to be
foolproof okay so that that's the great
hope is that Trump will be ousted by the
Muller report and the left sees
or sweeping in and none of this is good
for American politics this is why the
president would be well-served to sort
of go silence on Muller stuff until what
happens actually happens but that's not
the way our politics is moving this is
this is the deeply disturbing part about
our politics the radicals are getting
louder the people who want to have
honest conversations and actually drill
down into the terminology are being
obscured by folks who don't want to have
conversation they just want to rile up
their own base because every election is
now about base politics the media are
taking a part in this the worst story of
the weekend from the media was this
media freaked out over a guy named Joel
aronia Lara 36 was detained at a gas
station in San Bernardino where he and
his wife are on their way to the
hospital for her c-section he reportedly
had been living in the United States
illegally for 12 years and the entire
meeting went nuts how dare this happened
Kyle Griffin is a reporter I believe
over at NBC he said ice detained a man
while he was driving his pregnant wife
to the hospital he was taken when they
stopped for gas and they quoted his wife
saying my husband needs to be here he
had to wait for his son for so long and
someone just took him away Daniel Dale
who is a writer for I believe some the
Toronto Star he says the same thing
right oh it's so awful how dare I state
Amy's people representative Joe Kennedy
said there's heartless and then there's
whatever the hell this is I mean the
Kennedy family should know about
heartless leaving a woman to die in an
air bubble at the top of a car is not
exactly showing a lot of heart but the
entire media go nuts over all of this
there is only one problem with this
story it turns out the guy who was
arrested was arrested because he's
suspected of murder okay there's an
outstanding warrant for his arrest in
Mexico on homicide charges so this isn't
they just decided to pick up a guy who's
doing illegal immigrants at a gas
station while he's driving his wife to
the hospital for a c-section the guy is
legitimately a a suspected homicide
perpetrator so well done
media again driving politics to the to
its its best I think possible course
okay time for a Federalist Papers so
getting back to the foundations of the
country and the philosophy that has
supported it we go through a federalist
paper every week this week's Federalist
paper is Federalist 42 this is the
second most cited Federalist paper in
all of courts jurisprudence I believe
after Federalist 78 which we'll
eventually get to James Madison wrote
this one he talks about the powers of
the federal government including the
power to control foreign policy and
treaties and why the federal government
ought to have these power
there's one particular section that is
worth reading and that is the section in
which James Madison talks about the
Constitution and its designs toward
slavery so one of the great lies that
has been perpetrated by the political
left in the United States for a long
time is that the Constitution was
designed to enshrine slavery the
Constitution was designed to gradually
kill slavery here is James Madison
describing it hasn't just me saying this
this is James Madison writing at the
time it were doubtless to be wished but
the power of prohibiting the importation
of slaves had not been postponed until
the Year 1808 or rather than had been
suffered to have immediate operation and
he's saying I would rather if we just
gotten rid of the importation of slaves
like now but it is not difficult to
account either for this restriction on
the general government or for the manner
in which the whole clause is expressed
it ought to be considered as a great
point gained in favor of humanity that a
period of 20 years may terminate forever
within these states a traffic which is
so long and so loudly uprated the
barbarism of modern policy that within
that period it will receive a
considerable discouragement from the
federal government and may be totally
abolished by a concurrence of the few
states which constitute the unnatural
traffic in the prohibitory example which
has been given by so great majority of
the Union happy would it be for the
unfortunate Africans if an equal
prospect lay before them of being
redeemed from the oppressions of their
European brethren the idea that Madison
is espousing here as he thought and a
lot of the founders did that slavery
would go away a lot earlier than it
actually ended up going away instead the
South clung to slavery for decades
longer than then you know was not only
morally decent but even politically
necessary and that led to the civil war
but if the idea was that the
Constitution of the United States was
intended to protect slavery that is
simply not true it is simply not true it
was a compromised position adopted in
order to pass the Constitution but the
reason we got to that compromise is
because most people in the United States
because the northern was more heavily
heavily populated most of the people in
the United States were already in favor
of getting rid of slavery as early as
the adoption of the Constitution in all
likelihood and that was certainly true
in places like New York which is where
the Federalist Papers were originally
published the paper also discusses the
uniform power of preventing internal
tariffs the power to control citizenship
talks about why the government the
federal government has to have the power
over all of these but that section about
slavery is telling and is a good
rejoinder to all these folks who say
that the founding fathers were simply
attempting to enshrine slavery because
they loved it so much which is not true
James Madison by the way was a
southerner right is
Virginia all right so we'll be back here
tomorrow with all the latest I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah
of era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire Ford publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018